The Foundation was in chaos.
One minute, Dr. Bright was looking into some
harmless products on Amazon to help the Foundation's
anomalies have a nicer experience in their
cells.
The next, he was physically fighting for his
life against the company's CEO.
Of course, Dr. Bright’s wacky antics had
revealed the location of the SCP Foundation’s
most valuable containment site to Jeff Bezos
and his legions of minions.
Does Dr. Jack Bright have it in him to fix
his mistake, defeat the mighty Jeff Bezos,
and save the SCP Foundation from corporate
servitude?
Are the forces of the SCP Foundation equal
in strength to the Amazon horde?
And how, at the eleventh hour, will anomalies
like SCP-096, SCP-682, SCP-173, and SCP-049
help save the day?
Buckle up.
The only way to find out is to keep watching.
The two titans, Dr. Bright and the freakishly
buff Jeff Bezos, were locked into an intense
struggle.
The hapless immortal tried his best to punch
and kick the augmented CEO, but all it did
was make Bezos laugh.
“Pathetic, Jack,” Bezos roared.
“Let me show you how a real man does it.”
With one punch, Bezos sent Dr. Bright skidding
across the dirt, seeing stars.
Bezos punched him so hard, Dr. Bright felt
like he’d been hit by a runaway truck.
Where had he even gotten all this anomalous
technology?
Something more was going on here...
But before Dr. Bright could collect his thoughts,
Bezos was already upon him.
The ruthless business mogul clasped his hands
together and brought them down onto the back
of Jack’s head in a brutal pile drive, burying
his head in the dirt.
The guards of Site-19 looked on in terror
at the thousands of Amazon troops surrounding
them - And they were betting all this on a
fist fight?
And what’s more, it didn’t look like Dr.
Bright was winning that fist fight.
Unless the good doctor used his special move.
Bezos, still cackling like a Saturday morning
cartoon villain, grabbed Dr. Bright by his
hair and dragged him out of the dirt.
He lifted the Doctor, bloody and bashed, with
one hand.
At that moment, Dr. Bright knew that he had
to go with the nuclear option here - he needed
to use SCP-963 to take over the body of Jeff
Bezos and end this demented war.
“Had enough, Jack?”
Bezos said.
“Or do you want me to humiliate you even
more in front of your sad little employees?
Or, should I say, my sad little employees!”
Without another word, Dr. Bright grabbed the
amulet hanging around his neck and balled
it into his fist.
Moving as quickly as he could, he lunged at
Bezos with the medallion, knowing that one
touch should be enough to finish this whole
thing.
But then, the unexpected happened: Bezos caught
Dr. Bright’s hand.
The flesh of the CEO’s fist turned obsidian
black.
He gave a cruel smirk.
He was still himself.
Impossible…
All the SCP Foundation staff in attendance
were shocked and horrified, but none more
than Dr. Bright himself.
This was the first time that SCP-963 simply
hadn’t worked!
“I don’t understand,” Jack said, voice
trembling as Bezos squeezed his hand with
an iron grip.
“I should have taken you over.
How is this possible?”
Bezos chuckled before unleashing a brutal
headbutt on Dr. Bright, throwing him back
through the air.
Bright was lucky he managed to keep a grip
on the medallion - this body hadn’t worn
it for thirty days; if he dropped it, he would
have just been another useless necklace.
“Nanomachines, son!”
Bezos barked, cracking his neck back into
place.
“I had them designed with you in mind.
Any time and anywhere your necklace touches
me, they reshuffle my genetics to turn that
flesh into inanimate psuedometal.
Do you think I’d lead an assault on the
SCP Foundation without planning for every
possible eventuality?
I’ve been playing the long game!”
It was at this point that the Foundation guards
assembled outside the building opened fire
on Bezos, but it was no use.
The bullets just ricocheted off of his anomalously
enhanced physique.
He just gave a bellowing laugh and ordered
the full strength of his forces to move in.
As far as he was concerned, the fight was
already won.
If their forces could plant the grinning Amazon
flag in the heart of Site-19, the SCP Foundation
would be his.
It was time for the true final battle to begin.
Amazon’s troops loaded their weapons and
charged, firing volley after volley of bullets
onto the Foundation guards entrenched in their
positions.
Of course, the Foundation personnel was better
trained, but the Amazon army outnumbered them
ten to one.
It was only a matter of time until the barricades
gave way, and the forces spilled into the
containment facility.
And then they did.
Inside the building, Dr. Clef was reading
his new copy of Shotguns: A Comprehensive
Guide, when the army breached the perimeter.
It was at this point that he put down the
book and picked up his favorite shotgun, a
Remington Model 11-87 - fun fact: Also the
preferred weapon of Anton Chigurh from No
Country For Old Men - and entered the fray.
They’d need every SCP Foundation hand on
deck to repel the incoming attack.
The one thing that not even Dr. Clef predicted
was for the anomalies to get involved, too.
You see, in ordering his troops to attack
Site-19, the fleet of Amazon attack helicopters
above began launching AGM-114 Hellfire missiles
at the building to knock out guard towers
and strategic communications arrays.
This, however, had the unintended effect of
causing power fluctuations within the building,
and with so many of the reserve generators
devoted to maintaining external security against
the Amazon army, internal security failed
entirely.
In other words, a whole lot of cell doors
were popping open.
A group of Amazon footsoldiers was making
their way down hallway 6C when they saw something
strange on the ground: A tide of green, bubbling
chemicals that produced a horrific smell.
Little did they know, this was powerful hydrochloric
acid, but in this instance, it wasn’t the
acid that they should be worried about.
They heard a raspy voice behind them say...
“Disssgussssting...”
That’s when they turned to see SCP-682,
the giant, rage-fueled immortal reptile, standing
right behind them.
It had just finished its exotic beef jerky
collection, and now, it was eager for seconds.
The Amazon soldiers panicked and began to
open fire on the beast, but all that succeeded
in doing was annoying it.
SCP-682 leaped onto them and began devouring
the group of hapless mercenaries alive.
Elsewhere in the facility, another group of
Amazon mercenaries was chasing some defenseless
SCP Foundation researchers through the secure
humanoid containment wing.
The researchers tried to run, but soon, they
were backed into a corner.
The mercenaries laughed and leveled their
assault rifles.
This would be an easy kill.
However, the second they tried to fire, they
realized something extremely strange had occurred:
All of their guns had turned into delightful
bouquets.
Standing between them and the researchers
they intended to kill was SCP-343, also known
to some as God.
“Now, now, boys,” SCP-343 said with a
slight smile.
“Can’t we all just get along?
Make love, not war.”
Frightened by the seemingly impossible act
they just witnessed, the now unarmed mercenaries
ran into a nearby room with a sturdy-looking
door and locked themselves in.
Hopefully, nobody would get them here.
That thought was interrupted by a grandiose
voice with an archaic French accent speaking
out behind them.
“Why hello there, good sirs!
So kind of you to step into my practice today.”
They turned and saw a strange, robed man wearing
a runner pigeon mask.
The figure removed the mask, only to reveal
what seemed like another strange beaked mask
underneath.
It was SCP-049, his desk covered in pleasingly-polished
Amazon medical tools.
“My, my, you gents seem a little under the
weather.
This is a cause for concern,” the Plague
Doctor said as he began to walk toward the
frightened mercenaries.
“The Pestilence runs rife these days.
Not to worry, though.
I’m an expert.
And I’ve been itching to try out my lovely
new tools...”
Horrified screaming was heard from the room
shortly after, then silence.
But Amazon troops kept pouring in.
It was an all-out assault beyond any that
Site-19 had ever experienced.
Some Amazon strike teams were making their
way through the break rooms, hunting for more
Foundation employees to capture or execute.
One of them remarked that these SCP Foundation
employees must be real headcases - Why else
would they keep such a hideous concrete sculpture
in their break room?
Utterly bizarre.
The second they found there was no one inside
and turned to leave the room, they all lay
dead on the ground with snapped necks.
That would make it seventeen Amazon mercenaries
they’d killed today - The Sculpture was
having a truly wonderful time.
Meanwhile, over in his office, Dr. Clef was
fighting for his life.
A group of junior researchers were taking
refuge in there with him and handing him shotgun
shells from his many, many boxes of them when
he needed to reload.
Soldier after soldier was running into the
room, and Clef was using his trusty Remington
pump-action to blow them away with incredible
precision every time one of them ran in.
An awestruck researcher asked, “How good
are you with that thing?”
Clef laughed and said, “Kid, I could unbutton
your lab coat with it.”
But then tragedy struck: Dr. Clef ran out
of shells.
He sighed and told the assembled researchers
to run out of the back exit and save themselves.
He’d hold back the tide of Amazon mercenaries
alone.
He kissed his shotgun and said, “Forgive
me for this, Remy,” then grabbed it by the
barrel.
If he couldn’t shoot with it, he’d at
least use it as a club.
He ran out into the fray, bashing down mercenaries
left and right with his shotgun club until
he was finally outnumbered.
A group of heavily-armed soldiers surrounded
him, holding him at gunpoint.
One of them gave the order to fire.
“Wait!” Dr. Clef said.
“I can be valuable to you.
You don’t know who I am, do you?
Give me a second; let me show you my ID.”
Dr. Clef pulled an ID wallet from his lab
coat and showed it to the soldiers.
They looked at it, confused and a little disturbed.
The leader of the group said.
“That’s not an ID card, you schmuck.
What the hell is that ugly thing anyway?”
By this point, Dr. Clef had already closed
his eyes.
A distant screaming got closer and closer,
until the wall of his office exploded.
SCP-096 entered the room, shrieking with rage,
and began tearing the hapless soldiers to
shreds.
Clef rolled away, keeping his eyes closed
and waiting for the carnage to be over.
But in a grander sense, the carnage had only
just begun.
Oh, and for those who were curious, yes, SCP-811
did get her blobfish plushy.
She loved it.
Outside the facility, Jeff Bezos looked upon
the destruction he wrought and laughed.
It was just as wonderful as he’d imagined
it in all his years of intense planning for
this very moment.
It’d all unfolded exactly to his design.
The SCP Foundation would fall, and his master
plan would finally be complete.
Dr. Jack Bright, demoralized but not defeated,
rose shakily to his feet.
This whole disaster had been his fault.
Had had to redeem this.
He had to defeat Jeff Bezos, or the Foundation
would fall into his iron clutches.
Even if it finally, truly, killed him, Dr.
Bright would not give up.
“Impressive tech,” Dr. Bright said, cracking
his knuckles and getting Jeff’s attention
again.
“Which sweat shop built it for you?”
Jeff just laughed and turned to Bright again,
more than ready for round two.
“A little place called Prometheus Labs,
Jack,” Jeff said.
“Remember them?
I was on the board of directors before the
incident.
Just like you and your Foundation dogs, they
left behind plenty of goodies for me.”
Dr. Bright charged at Bezos, screaming in
animal fury.
He punched the smug anomalous businessman
square in the jaw.
Bezos barely even flinched.
He gave Jack an utterly brutal open-handed
slap, knocking him towards the entrance to
Site-19, where more Amazon soldiers were still
pouring in.
Still, Jack began to stand again.
“What the hell does a corporate stiff like
you want with the SCP Foundation?” he said.
“We want to help the world, not rule it.”
Bezos sneered and began stomping toward the
immortal doctor.
“I don’t just want to rule the world,
Jack.
I want to hold it in my hand like an apple
and take a big, juicy bite.
All that exists will belong to me,” he said,
throwing a punch that Dr. Bright was thankfully
able to dodge.
“That’s always been the plan, and the
SCP Foundation is the final piece I need.”
Dr. Bright, summoning all the adrenaline in
his body, unleashed a flurry of sharp punches
to Jeff’s abdomen.
He simply tanked every strike and laughed.
“I’ve been funding the Chaos Insurgency
for years, Jack.
I’m one of Marshall, Carter, and Dark’s
largest shareholders.
Amazon is Dr. Wondertainment’s primary global
distributor.
The Sarkicists, The Fifthists, The Mekhanites,
those pretentious art snobs at Are We Cool
Yet, they’re all in my deep pockets!”
Jeff roared.
He wrapped one of his massive hands around
Dr. Bright’s throat and lifted him clear
off the ground.
Jack struggled against his grip.
“You’ve spent decades worrying about all
the wrong things, Jack,” Jeff said, slowly
tightening his grip around Dr. Bright’s
throat.
“The Devourer Of Worlds?
The Black Moon?
The Scarlet King?
My new world won’t have a king.
It’ll have a CEO.
And with the power within these walls, I’ll
be the Chairman of the Cosmic Board!
And it all starts with me killing you and
turning your silly little necklace into a
paperweight!”
But Jack had an ace up his sleeve.
Something he had the good sense to pocket
before facing Bezos on the battlefield.
He reached into his lab coat and pulled out
SCP-662, The Butler’s Hand Bell.
One little ring and Mr. Deeds suddenly appeared
right next to them.
Jack barely managed to wheeze out, “Deeds,
kick Jeff in the groin!”
“Of course, sir, “ Mr. Deeds said, before
doing exactly that.
Jeff winced in pain and loosened his grip
on Dr. Bright’s neck.
The plucky immortal took his chance to wriggle
free from Jeff’s grip and run into the facility,
yelling back, “Deeds, stall him!”
But before Deeds could execute this order,
Jeff Bezos fractured the anomalous butler’s
skull with a single punch, and chased Dr.
Bright into the facility.
He would have his revenge!
As Dr. Bright fled, he grabbed his Foundation
walkie-talkie and frantically spoke into it,
“Clef, I’m in big trouble!
I think I have a way to stop this, but there’s
just something you need to do for me first...”
Battles were raging on throughout the site.
Some Amazon soldiers had unloaded their rifles
into Cain, only to find themselves on the
floor, dying of massive blood loss.
Other squadrons of mercenaries were being
tortured by the nightmarish SCP-106 in his
terrifying pocket dimension.
He was having a wonderful time.
SCP-999 was even tickling a gaggle of Amazon’s
hired veteran war criminals into absolute
submission.
Much to Jeff’s rage and horror, it looked
like, with the help of the anomalies, the
Foundation might actually be able to turn
the tide.
This would not do.
He’d destroy Bright and take care of the
rest personally.
“It has to be this way, Jack!”
Bezos yelled after the fleeing doctor.
“I’m making the mother of all corporate
omelets here, can’t fret over a few ransacked
containment sites!”
Bezos’ self-aggrandizing rants were interrupted
by SCP-682 leaping onto him out of an adjoining
hallway, giving Dr. Bright even more time
to create distance between them.
682 fought valiantly and viciously, but Jeff’s
Prometheus Labs nanomachine augmentations
gave him the edge.
He was able to get 682 into a headlock, Steve
Irwin style, then punch it in the head until
it was knocked out.
Jeff sighed, relieved, and continued the chase
after Jack.
As Jeff turned a corner to chase Dr. Bright,
he ran right into one of Jack’s traps.
There was Dr. Bright, standing about fifteen
feet away from him, holding his favorite item
that he normally wasn’t allowed to use:
The Chainsaw Cannon.
Jack smirked and said, “Smile, you son of
a—“
BOOM!
A chainsaw projectile blasted towards Jeff
at incredible speeds.
It was through pure luck and superhuman reflexes
that Jeff was able to catch it between his
palms by the blade and hold it in place, even
as it cut into his nanite-hardened skin.
With a grunt of rage, he threw the saw to
the ground.
“Is that all you got, Jack?” he growled.
“Not quite,” Dr. Bright replied.
“I’ve got a few friends who owe me some
favors.”
Suddenly, Bezos heard footsteps behind him.
He turned to see three figures standing there,
primed and ready for battle: SCP-4494, The
Specter, SCP-5151 The Black Knight, and SCP-2800,
Cactusman.
“You fight without honor, Sir Jeffrey!”
The Black Knight proclaimed as he drew his
longsword.
“Aye, and I can’t stand bullies!”
Said Cactusman as his spikes began to grow.
“Wage theft and tax evasion is a crime,
evildoer!”
The Specter added.
“Well, then,” Jeff said.
“I suppose I’ll just have to kill you
all...”
The fight began.
Our group of four heroes held their own impressively,
to begin with.
They consistently helped each other block
or avoid the deadly strikes that Bezos was
unleashing and return their own.
Four anomalies against one.
The Black Knight even gave Dr. Bright one
of his spare swords to give him a better chance
of landing a meaningful blow against Bezos.
But in the end, it was all for nothing.
Bezos powered up, his nanomachines drawing
energy from the building around him, until
he was even larger and stronger.
In his state, he easily beat down his four
attackers, incapacitating them and standing
over Bright.
“It’s useless, Jack,” he said with another
evil laugh.
“You can’t beat me.”
“I know,” Jack groaned in pain.
“But I did a pretty good job of stalling
you.”
At that moment, Clef came running down the
hall, wielding another firearm.
But it wasn’t a shotgun this time.
In fact, it didn’t even look like a real
gun, it looked like a spray-painted Nerf gun.
That got another laugh out of Jeff.
What an utterly feeble attempt.
That’s when Dr. Clef leveled the nerf gun
and fired one of its darts at Jeff’s chest,
where it seemed to bounce off uselessly.
“Really?”
He asked, incredulous.
“Come on.
This is just getting—“
His words were cut off by an uppercut from
Dr. Bright.
Inexplicably, he actually felt that one.
Jeff staggered back, rubbing his jaw as Bright
rose to his feet.
“How the hell did you hurt me?”
Jeff muttered, genuinely shocked.
Dr. Bright smirked.
“That was the Nerfing Gun, chrome dome.
We just made your precious nanomachines useless.”
With another incredibly well-earned punch
in the face from Dr. Bright, Jeff was down
on the ground with a bleeding nose.
Elsewhere in the facility, the researchers,
guards, and anomalies working together had
defeated the dark forces of Amazon.
Outside, Hammer Down - The largest and most
militarily powerful Mobile Task Force - had
arrived and wiped out what remained of Jeff’s
invasion force outside.
It wasn’t easy, but the SCP Foundation had
won.
As Jeff lay on the ground, holding his broken
nose, Dr. Bright held him at sword point.
“Wait, Wait!” Jeff said.
“Let’s not let hard feelings linger.
We’re both adults, right?
And I’m a businessman.
I make deals.
Compromises.
I can give you anything from the Amazon stock,
free of charge!
As long as we agree that I can go and we forget
all this!”
Dr. Bright smiled and thought it over.
“Well...” he said.
“There are a few things I think I’d like
for myself.
And there are still plenty more anomalies
that need enriching...”
Victory secured.
Want another video abo but the deranged things
Dr. Bright bought for even more anomalies
and Foundation staff?
Let us know down in the comments, and we’ll
continue the strangest story that the SCP
Foundation’s most eccentric researcher ever
told...
Now go check out “SCP Edition - Weird Things
On Amazon - Dr. Bright’s Great Idea!”
and “SCP-001 When Day Breaks Dr. Bright”
for more of the mad doctor’s most peculiar
adventures!